[Müzik]
Selam gençler kimya adasını kimya Adası
ders kanalına Hoş geldiniz canlar 9lar
ne var ne yok Umarım herkes iyidir
Herkese selamlarımı gönderiyorum Evet
Maarif modeline göre 9 sınıf kimya
derslerini işlemeye devam ediyoruz
Umarım sizlere fayda sağlıyorum durur
gençler birinci temanın da bu arada
sonuna doğru geldik yani burada atom
çapı iyonlaşma enerjisi ve
elektronegatiflik gibi kavramlar var
Bunları da sizlere sırasıyla anlatacağım
zaten ki bu dersimizin konusu da atom y
çapı Haydi bakalım dersimizde başlayalım
çalışmalarımıza Evet atom yarıçapı
deyince ne anlıyoruz Bak burada benim
elimde bazı oyuncaklar var Bunlar böyle
küre yuvarlak gibi görüyorsunuz ki
oyuncaklar bunları atom gibi düşünürsek
bunların büyüklüğünü ifade edersek ne
yapacağız Tabii ki bunların yarı
çaplarını düşüneceğiz yarıçapı büyükse
çapı büyüktür Dolayısıyla atomum
büyüktür Hatta Bunlar küre olduğu için
hacmi de düşünülebilir yani O zaman
şöyle düşünebilirsiniz atom yarıçapı
demek aslında atom çapı demektir aynı
zamanda kıyaslamada ya da işte atom
hacminin kıyaslanması da aynı şekildedir
diye bakarsanız o zaman Bunlar atomlar
küresel oldukları için atom yarıçapının
ifadesi Aslında atomun büyüklüğünü ifade
eder diyeceğiz Yani biz burada Aslında
atomların büyüklüğünü Biz anlayacağız ve
açıklamaya çalışacağız Pekala Her atomun
büyüklüğü aynı olabilir mi E tabii ki
olamaz burada ne vardır Bizim bir tane
Tabii ki merkezimiz var çekirdeğim Var
tabii dağılımdaki ne vardır elektronlar
mız var Bak görüyorsun Çünkü helyum bir
katmanda 2 elektron var görüyorsun ki
Evet 2 elektron burada bir katmanı var o
zaman bunun yarıçapına bakarsak bu kadar
mesafesi var değil mi Ama neona
bakarsanız neonun iki katmanı var O
zaman en dıştaki oradaki elektron
uzaklığı burada görüyorsun He o zaman
demek ki atomların büyüklükleri farklı
oluyorsa da yarıçapları da farklı oluyor
o zaman burada biz Aslında atom
çekirdeği ile ne yapıyoruz en dış
katmanda bulunan elektron arasındaki
mesafeyi Biz burada belirliyoruz İşte
buradaki mesafe
atom yarıçapını ifade eder Peki bunları
biz ölçeceğiz mi ölçemeyiz onlar ancak
elektron mikroskobuyla falan ölçülür ve
bunların değerleri çok çok küçük Aslında
pikometre dediğimiz değer pikometre çok
küçüktür Mesela şöyle anlatayım ben size
1 M = 10 üzeri -12 pikometre yani
nanometreden bile küçük nanometreyi
belki biliyorsundur 1 metre eşit 10
üzeri -9 nanometredir mesela Dolayısıyla
şimdi Tabii ki burada hiç Endişelenme
gerek yok bu değerleri ben size
veriyorum ama Genel kültür olsun diye
veriyorum Bunları size sormuyoruz Hani
pikometre falan biz burada atomun
büyüklüğünü falan hesaplamaya sadece
kıyaslama yapacağız bunu da burada
belirtmek isterim Pekala acaba Per 3
cetvelde nasıl değişir Hadi bakalım bunu
anlamaya çalışalım şimdi atom yarıçapı
deyince Öncelikle Aynı grupta diye
düşünürseniz mesela 2 A grubunu
düşünelim fark etmez aşağı doğru
gidildikçe katman sayısı artıyor ve bu
durumda atom çapı artar Peki aynı
periyotta biz böyle aynı periyotta
soldan sağa doğru gidersek proton sayısı
arttığı için Dolayısıyla burada ne
yaparlar elektronlar daha çok çekilirler
merkeze doğru ve atom çapı O zaman bu
durumda azalır Yani şöyle bir şey
yapalım Aynı grupta bir yönüne doğru
gidersek Yani aşağı doğru gidersek aynı
periyotta da iki yönüne doğru gidersek
yani sağdan sola doğru gidersek atom
çapımız O zaman bu durumda artar ama 3
ve 4 yönüne doğru gidersek de tam
tersine gidersek de azalır diyoruz Şimdi
bunu unutmamanız için şöyle bir şey
yapacağım ben buraya bir tane Kardın
adam çizim görüyorsun ki Kardın Adamın
neyi vardır bir kafası vardır değil mi
Bak bir kafa vardır burada görüyorsun ki
bir tane gövde vardır Evet görüyorsun
Bir de bunun neyi var bir burnu var bak
burnu da şöyle olsun böyle bir burun
çizelim Buraya şimdi tamam mı Şimdi
aslında burada ü tane atom varmış gibi
düşünelim bak burası burnu x atomu Evet
şu kafası y atomu gövdesi de Z atomu
gibi düşünürsen E şimdi burada kimin
yarıçapı daha büyük Tabii ki bak böyle
gidersek ve böyle gidersek yarı çapımız
artıyor mu evet görüyorsun O zaman
burada durumda Z'nin yarıçapı en
büyüktür Hani daha büyük Çünkü ki den
y'den y'nin yarıçapı da x'ten daha
büyüktür o zaman demek ki hani
unutmazsınız diye düşünüyorum Aynı
grupta aşağı doğru gidersek aynı
periyotta ise sola doğru gidersek atom
çapımız artar
diyoruz Hadi bakalım şimdi burada bir
sorumuz var bunu hem anlatalım hem de
Sebebini de açıklayalım beraber elimize
görüyorsun ki sodyum magnezyum ve
potasyum vermişiz bunların çaplarını
kıyaslayınız diye sormuşum Şimdi ne
yapacağız Öncelikle yer bulacağız Tabii
ki yani katman dağılımını yapalım
sodyumun proton sayısı 10 11 elektron
sayısı da 11 Bak 2 elektron 1in katmanda
8 elektron 2ci katmanda 1 elektron 3
katmanda Bak 3 katmanı var yani Bak
düşün sodyum bir çekirdeği var etrafında
1 2 3 katmanı var böyle bir katman var o
zaman buradaki yarı çapımız bu kadar
değil mi sodyum için bu kadar peki bunu
hallettikten sonra magnezyuma bakalım
magnezyum proton sayısı 12 elektron
sayısı da 12 2 elektron 1ci katmanda 8
elektron 2ci katmanda ve 2 elektron da
son katmanda Bak bu da aynı şekil
şekilde görüyorsun ki bir tane çapımız
çekirdeğim var Merkezde 1 2 3 tane
katmanımı var o zaman bunun da yarıçapı
ne kadardır şu kadardır Gördün mü böyle
bir durum vardır Peki devam edelim şimdi
diğeri neymiş diğeri de potasyumu hemen
potasyuma baktığın zaman 19 protonu var
19 elektronu var 2 elektron 1ci katmanda
8 elektron ikinci katmanda 8 elektron
son katmanda bir elektron da E tabii ki
en dış katmanda oluyor o zaman potasyuma
bakarsanız e tane çekirdeğim var 1 2 3
ve 4 katmanı var değil mi he katman
sayısı artmış E bu durumda şimdi
yarıçapı ne kadar potasyum bu kadar
öncelikle şunu düşünürsün değil mi
katman sayısı arttıkça Tabii ki ne
oluyor bu durumda Yarıçap artıyor yani
buradaki mesafeyle bunlar aynı mıdır
değildir o zaman bu durumda şunu
düşünebilirsin hemen potasyumun katman
sayısı arttığı için potasyumun çapı daha
büyüktür Pekala diğerlerini kıyaslarsan
e burada eşitlik var üçer katman o zaman
Bunlar eşit midir acaba Hayır bak hiçbir
zaman bir kere eşit olmuyor peki burada
Neye bakacaksın burada şuna bakacaksın
Bak şimdi burada sodyum 11 tane protonla
11 elektronu kendine doğru çekiyor tamam
mı E magnezyum da 12 tane protonla 12
elektronu kendine doğru çekiyor nasıl bu
oluyor şöyle oluyor bizim zaten Merkezde
protonlar var Artı yüklü elektronlar da
katmanlarda değil mi E şimdi protonlar
ne yapar merkezde artı yüklü oldukları
için zıt yüklü oldukları için
elektronları kendine doğru çekerler
Pekala E şimdi burada önemli olan
elektron başına dü çekim kuvveti Şimdi
burada şunu düşünebilirsin E hocam 11
Proton 11 elektronu kendine doğru
çekiyor e 12 Proton da 12 elektronu
kendine doğru çekiyor Yani bir Proton
bir elektron Çekiyor o zaman yine
eşitmiş gibi düşünebilirsin ama hayır
düşünme Neden biliyor musun olay şöyle
bir şey var şimdi burada bir protonun
kütlesi bir tane elektronun kütlesinin
yaklaşık olarak 2000 katı yani şimdi bak
şöyle bir şey burada Normalde 11 tane
elektron vardı 11 Proton vardı ya şimdi
magnezyumda 12 elektron oldu buraya
atıyorum mesela 1 kilogram daha geldi
diyelim buraya ağırlık olar olarak ama
buraya bir Proton daha gelince 12 Proton
olunca Burası magnezyum olunca Burası +
2000 kg gibi oldu o zaman merkeze daha
fazla ağırlık bindiği için o zaman
buradaki elektronlar hop buraya daha çok
çekilir yani protonun kütlesi çok fazla
olduğu için o zaman bu durumda elektron
başına düşen çekim kuvveti artar o zaman
ne oluyor bu durumda kimin çapı daha
büyük oluyor sodyumun çapı o zaman
magnezyumun çapından büyük oluyor yani
katman sayısı eşitse Proton sayısının
büyük olması Biz burada atom çapını
küçül düğünü anlıyoruz Peki hocam bunun
daha pratik yöntemi var mı E tabii ki
var Hemen Sen bunun yöntemini şöyle
bulabilirsin demin anlattım ya bak
Potasyum nerede 4 katmanı var yani 4
periyot elementi derk elektron sayısı 1
bir a grupu elementi Peki magnezyuma
bakalım kaç katmanı var 3 katmanı var Bu
da 3 periyot 2A Grup elementi çünkü dik
elektron sayısı yani valans elektron
sayısı 2 görüyorsun ki sodyuma bak 3
tane katmanı var 3ün periyot bir A grubu
elementi Şimdi benim burada bir hani
şöyle bir çizeyim isterseniz bir kesit
çizeyim isterseniz iki tane periyodum
var İki grubum var 1A grubu var ve 2A
grubu var tabii ki burası 3 periyot
olsun Burası da 4 periyot olsun sodyum
zaten şurada magnezyum hemen yanında ve
potasyum burada nasıl artıyordu bir
periyotta sola doğru giderken artar bir
grupta İsa aşağı doğru giderse o zaman
en büyük potasyum oluyor zaten
Dolayısıyla potasyumun çapı sodyumdan
büyük sodyumun çapı da magnezyumdan
büyük diye de böyle yazabiliriz tamam mı
olay bu şekilde
yapılır Şimdi bir tane notumuz var Bu
nota beraber odaklanmanız istiyorum
şimdi gençler bazen iyonlar mız var
tamam mı iyon dediğimiz şey nedir yüklü
olan tanecikler
mizdeki bu nötrdür proton sayısı
elektron sayısına eşit ama magnezyum Bak
şimdi 2 elektron verirse proton sayısı
aynı kalır elektron sayısı 10'a düşer ve
E artı yüklüler elektronlardan iki
farklı olunca ik fazla olunca + 2 ile
yüklenir Yani biz buna O zaman ne
diyoruz bir Atom elektron verirse katyon
haline gelir katyon artı yüklü iyondur
Peki bu durumda ne oluyor bakarsanız Bak
şimdi şöyle bir şey oluyor değil mi
burada 12 Proton 12 elektronu kendine
doğru çekerken Şimdi 12 Proton 10
elektronu kendine doğru çekiyor E daha
çok çekilmez mi bu elektronlar merkeze
doğru Yani bizim şimdi çekirdeğim var bu
çekirdeğin etrafında elektronlar var
elektronlar daha çok kuvvetle çekilir
elektron başına düşen Çünkü çekim
kuvveti artar Yani gene 12 tane Proton
var ama Eskiden 12 elektron çek yordu
şimdi o elektron daha rahat çekilir o
zaman elektron başına düşen çekim
kuvveti artar E bu durumda e burada daha
böyle katman yanaşacak için merkeze
doğru çapımız ne olur bu durumda azalır
diyoruz o zaman kimin çapı daha büyüktür
Tabii ki buradaki magnezyum nötr halinin
çapı artı yüküne göre daha fazladır
deriz Peki bakalım başka bir şey daha
var flor diyelim florun proton sayısı 9
elektron sayısı da 9 tamam mı nötr
haldeyken Tabii ki flor bir tane
elektron alsın o zaman bu durumda ne
olur 9 Proton olurken elektron sayısı 10
olur ve -1 ile yüklenir Yani bu durumda
Eğer bir tanecik atomum elektron alırsa
bir anyon yapısına döner E bu durumda ne
olur Bak eskiden 9 protonla 9 elektronu
kendime doğru çekerken şimdi 9 protonla
10 elektron kendime doğru çekerken
zorlanırım Dolayısıyla elektron başına
düşen çekim kuvvetinin azaldığını
görebiliyorum E bu durumda ne olur
çapımız da bu durumda Tabii ki artar
değil mi Çünkü daha E az kuvvetle
çekiyorum elektronları kendine doğru
şimdi ben burada o zaman kimin çapı daha
büyük dersek flor -1'in çapı floran daha
büyük olduğunu söyleyebilirim Bak şimdi
burada iki tane çocuk var Onu
görebiliyorsun dur diye düşünüyorum
bunun adı Sami olsun bunun adı da Hami
olsun Tamam mı Şimdi sami'ye bakalım
Sami ne yapmış gençler Sami bayağı obez
bir arkadaşımız çok seviyor yemeği işte
elinde Bak görüyorsun Pizza var
ceplerinde böyle cipsler falan var
Yedikçe şişiyor Yedikçe de kilo alıyor
ve çapı artıyor değil mi o zaman şimdi
şöyle bir şey diyebilir miyiz biz mesela
yemeği çok yersek yersek yersek ne olur
kilo alırız kilo alırsak çapımız artar
göbeğimizin çapı artar işte atom da
elektron alıyor alıyor alıyor elektron
yiyor ve çapı artıyor yani Elektron alan
tahin çapı artar burada bunu
anlayabiliriz Peki diğerine Bakalım
burada ise Hami var Hami ne yapıyor Hami
koşuyor Hami spor yapıyor Hami spor
yaptıkça tel atıyor e tel attıkça
zayıflıyor değil mi o zaman da göbeğinin
çapı azalmış oluyor o zaman biz şimdi
Spor yaparsak ne yaparız zayıflarız ve
bu durumda hani çapımız azalır ya o
zaman bu durumda bir Atom elektron
verirse zayıflarsa da o zaman ne olur
çapı azalır diyoruz o zaman demek ki
böyle bir şey düşünebilirsiniz Elektron
alan taneciğin çapı artar elektron veren
taneciğin ise çapı azalır bu şekilde
bunu söylemiş
oluyoruz şimdi Haydi bir uygulama
yapalım daha iyi anlayacağını
düşünüyorum Burada şimdi ben bazı
tanecikler verdim görüyorsun ki bunların
çaplarını kıyaslayın diye sormuşum Bak
burada hem atom var içerisinde hem iyon
var Nasıl yapacağız bakalım şimdi
alüminyum + 3 var ama önce Tabii ki
proton sayısı 13' müş + 3 olunca
elektron sayısı 10'a düşecek Tabii ki
biz ne yapalım 2 8 8 kuralına göre daha
kolay olur 2 elektron 1in katmanda 8
elektron da ikinci katmanda Bak görüyor
musun İki katmanı kalmış alüminyumun
peki Yani iyon halinin alüminyum Bir de
nötr hali var görüyorsun ki 13 protonu
var 13 de elektronu var E Dolayısıyla
bak şimdi bu nötr hali 2 elektron 8
Elektron ve 3 elektron bak şu anda
görüyorsun ki 3 katmanı var Evet birinci
merkezden 3 katman olduğunu
görebiliyorsun Peki flor ek 1'e bakalım
flor -1 baktığın zaman Evet ne
göreceksin Tabii ki burada 9 protonu
varken elektron sayısı 10 olur ve bu
durumda 2 elektron birinci katmanda 8
elektron ikinci katmanda olarak
yazabilirim Peki potasyuma bakalım
potasyum proton sayısı kaçmış 19' Muş
hemen yazıyoruz 2 elektron 1 katmanda 8
elektron 2ci katmanda 8 elektron 3
katmanda ve Ne kaldı bir elektron kaldı
evet bu da 4 katmanlı görüyorsun ki
diğeri ne kalsiyum kalsiyumun da 20 tane
protonu var 20 tane de elektronu var
zaten potasyumda 19 elektronu vardı
zaten götürdü Çünkü kalsiyum da nötür 2
elektron 1ci katmanda 8 elektron 2ci
katmanda 8 elektron 3C katmanda ve Ne
Kaldı 2 elektron son katmanda şimdi
bunların çaplarını kıyaslarsan Bak şimdi
düşünsene bir merkezim var katman sayısı
arttıkça ne olur Çapın Tabii ki artar
Dolayısıyla Burada kimin çapı daha büyük
diye bakarsak katman sayısı büyük
olanların Evet görüyor musun Yani bir
kere potasyum ve kalsiyumun çapı
diğerlerine göre daha büyüktür Peki ben
bunları nasıl kıyasları bak potasyuma
baktığın zaman kaç kat katmanı var 4
katmanı var Hemen 4 periyot 1A grubu
olduğunu görebiliyorum Çünkü derk
elektron sayısı 1 kalsiyuma bakalım kaç
katmanı var 4 katmanı var Bak görüyorsun
1 2 3 4 katmanı var o da 4 periyot
elementi değer elektron sayısı 2 olursa
da bu da 2A grubu elementi olmuş oluyor
E şimdi iki tane elementim var Bunlar
potasyum ve kalsiyum E şimdi burası 4
periyot görüyorsun ki 1A grubunda kim
var 2A grubunda kim var 1A grubunda
potasyum var 2A grubunda kalsiyum var ee
sola doğru gidersek aynı periyotta
çapımız artardı demiştim Dolayısıyla
Burada en büyük Çapa sahip olan kimdir
potasyum sonra kalsiyum diyeceğiz Evet
bunu böyle yazdık Peki sonra üç katmanlı
yani alüminyumun nötr hali görüyor musun
Onun 3 katmanı var o zaman demek ki
alüminyum çapı gelir Peki Diğerlerine
bakalım şimdi orada ne var Bak burada
alüminyum + 3 iyonu görüyor musun burada
da flor -1 iyonu Aslında ikisinin de 28
iki tane katmanı var Evet eşit mi Hayır
eşit değil Neden Bak şimdi alüminyum + 3
iyonunda 13 tane protonla biz bu
elektronları çekiyoruz merkeze doğru ama
flaa 9 protonla çekiyoruz hangisi daha
kolay çeker 13 Proton 10 elektronu
Kendine çok daha rahat çeker o zaman
buradaki elektronlar katmanlar merkeze
yanaştığı için çapımız küçülür O zaman
bu durumda flor -1'in çapı kimden
büyüktür alüminyum + 3'ten büyüktür Bak
görüyor musun alüminyum nötr haldeki
çapı + 3 yüklü daha büyük oldu elektron
verince çapımız küçüldü burada bunu
görüyorsunuz ve sıralamayı ben bu
şekilde yaptım Umarım anlamışsındır
şimdi Ne yapalım biraz soru çözelim test
soru soruları çözelim Haydi bakalım
şimdi görüyorsun ki elimizde bir tane
koşu parkuru var demişiz ki Leyla hayali
bir engelli koşu parkuru hazırlamak
istemektedir Evet Pekala ne yapacakmış
Leyla engel olarak atomları kullanmayı
hedefleyen Leyla sporcuları koşuya
alıştırmak için engelleri küçük olandan
büyük olana doğru sıralamayı
planlamıştır yani atomları kullanacak
mış ve kalbi çok temiz ne yapacak Hani
Sporcular alışsın düşmesinler diye küçük
alan atomu önce koyuyor sonra büyüye
doğru gidiyormuş falan filan Peki Buna
göre engel olarak kullanmak istediği
kükürt neon kalsiyum hidrojen ve
potasyum atomlarını hangi sırayla acaba
bu piste yerleştirilmelidir diye sormuş
hemen yer bulacaksınız Tabii ki ve buna
göre kıyaslama yapacaksınız şimdi kükürt
var elimizde proton sayısı 16 bak ne
olur 2 elektron 1ci katmanda 8 elektron
ikinci katmanda 6 elektron son katmanda
Bak 3 katmanı var Dolayısıyla bu 3ün
periyot elementi değer ktron sayısı 6
olduğuna göre 6a grup elementidir Bunu
gördük Şimdi devam edelim diğeri kimmiş
diğeri de neonu neonun proton sayısı 10'
muu elektron sayısı 10 şu anda Hepsi
bunların atom zaten görüyorsunuz ki 2
elektron 1ci katmanda 8 elektron 2ci
katmanda E bu da 2 periyot elementi ve
8A grubu elementidir bunu da burada
görebiliyoruz Peki devam edelim Diğeri
kim diğeri de evet kalsiyum kalsiyumu da
hemen şuraya yazayım Demin de yaptım
aslında kalsiyum 20 Proton 20 elektronu
2 8 8 2 Nerede bu bu da 4 katman 4
periyot 2A grubu elementi olduğunu
görebiliyorum sonra hidrojen varmış
hidrojen zaten Çok basit bir Proton var
bir de elektron var bir elektron var
zaten 1ci katmanda ve bu da 1 periyot 1
A grupu elementi olduğunu görebiliyorum
Diğeri kim diğeri de zaten yapılmıştı
aslında ama yapalım gene potasyum 19 19
da elektronu var 2 elektron 1ci katmanda
8 elektron 2ci katmanda 8 elektron 3
katmanda bir elektron da son katmanda
toplam 4 katmanı var ve 4 periyot
elementi ve 1 A grubu elementi olduğunu
gördük Şimdi burada 4 tane
5 elementim var 4 tane periyoda Bunlar
yayılmış şöyle ben bunu isterseniz
yapayım Böyle bir 1 2 3 4 diyelim bak
şurası 1 periyodun 1A grubu olarak
düşünürsek şurası hidrojen Burası 1
periyot Burası 2 periyot Burası 3
periyot Burası 4 periyot gibi
düşünebilirsiniz Evet 2 periyodun son
elementi kim 8A grubu elementinde Kim
varmış neon varmış Bak neonu buraya
yazarız E peki 4 4 periyotta kim var
tabii ki burada potasyum var hemen
yanında 2A grubunda Kim varmış Orada
Tabii ki magnezyum varmış Bunu yazdım
Başka ne var tabii ki 3ün periyotta da
kükürt varmış e o da zaten 6 A'da bak
şurası 6a olsun tamam mı 6 A'da Kim
varmış kükürt bunu böyle yazabiliyoruz
Tamam E şimdi bak 5 elementi yazdım
nasıl değişirdi bir periyotta sola doğru
artar bir grupta ise aşağı doğru artar
Ama önce aşağıda olanlara bakacaksın
yani burada kim aşağıda Tabii ki
potasyum ve magnezyum aşağıda ve solda
olan potasyum O zaman burada ben
çaplarını kıyaslarsan potasyum çapı
magnezyum magnezyum diyorum Pardon
magnezyum değil ya olur mu Arkadaşlar şu
kalsiyumlu zaten düzeltiyorum şunu
düzeltelim olur mu şöyle düzeltelim
Yanlış olmuştu onu Evet şu potasyum şu e
kalsiyumdan edelim sonra bak ne var
kükürt var görüyorsun ki aşağıda o zaman
kükürtün çapı Tabii ki daha büyüktür
sonra kim olur Bak şimdi şöyle bir şey
var neon sağda hidrojen solda ama neon
daha aşağıda kimin çapı daha büyüktür
önce aşağıda olana bakacaksın yani
neonun çapı daha büyüktür sonra hidrojen
yani sonra gruba bakıyorsun tamam mı O
zaman neon zaten yazılır ve hidrojen de
buraya oluşturulur Peki bunu böyle
yazdıktan sonra ben şimdi bunu böyle
yazdım büyükten küçüğe yazdım ama
alıştırmak istiyorum küçükten büyüğe
yazmam gerekiyor o zaman önce hidrojeni
sonra neonu sonra kükürtü sonra
kalsiyumu en sona da potasyumu koyarsam
oradaki Sporcular düşmezler diye
düşünüyoruz cevap da bu durumda C
seçeneğidir deriz inşallah anlamışsındır
bir sorumuz daha geldi burada bir
tablomuz var bu tablo Neyi gösteriyormuş
bize x elementinin ve oluşturduğu bazı
iyonlarının yarıçapları Aşağıdaki
tabloda verilmiş demiş Buna göre acaba
hangi tanecik yond dur diye sormuş şimdi
bak X'in burada görüyorsun ki yükü 0
zaten burada atomdur Mesela diyelim ki
17 protonu varken 17 elektronu varmış ve
buradaki tcik yarıçapı 70 hani şunu
söylemiştim ya bir tanecik elektron
alırsa elektron alırsa ne oluyordu kilo
alıyordu yani çapı artardı E şimdi
70'ten kim daha büyük bakalım Evet Bak
görüyorsun 171 var aynı zamanda 102 var
he o zaman xk ve XP elektron olarak
anyon haline gelmiş ve bu durumda çapı
artmış Dolayısıyla burada x K'nın anyon
xp'nin de anyon olduğunu anlayabiliriz
Hatta tam tersinde de bakarsan xm 62 xn
de 48 yani 70'e göre küçülmüş o zaman
demek ki şöyle söyleyebiliriz xm ve xn
de burada katyondur Hatta ne kadar Kim
daha fazla küçülürse o daha fazla
Elektron vermiş demektir yükü daha fazla
artmıştır O zaman bu durumda n değeri
m'den de büyüktür atıyorum mesela M
değeri + 1 ise M değeri mesela + 2 de
olabilir çünkü elektron verdikçe çapımız
küçülüyor Evet Peki bu durumda anyonu
kimler anyonu xk ve XP cevap da e
şıkkıdır diyoruz Evet atom çapını
anlattık iyon çapını anlattık İnşallah
anlamışsınızdır tabii ki bir sonraki
dersimizde iyonlaşma enerjisini de
anlatacağım hiç böyle endişe en Mene
gerek yok sınavlarından da yüksek almanı
İnşallah bu şekilde sağlayacağız
İnşallah Kimyayı daha çok seveceksin
Hadi bakalım kendine iyi bak Görüşmek
üzere
[Müzik]